[Music]
my name is Peter Santaniello in this
it's beneath Keith where we journey
together in the key of Ukraine through
the eyes of the locals five episodes
five completely different stories one
amazing city
[Music]
[Applause]
go go go Alexander
yeah and that's the meter there today
well actually the next few days you're
gonna show a song an American audience
and Ukrainian audience and a world
audience your Keith your city yep
I'll try
[Music]
so Alexander well we picked him up
gangster style in the back of a car but
then he said why don't we just drive my
sweet new Volvo around and I said well
that makes better sense so we're
completely on Alexander's program right
now going to his places
let's start from coffee okay cafe okay
cool yeah I need some coffee morning
coffee
[Music]
put that in there if there's someone to
call you yeah justify but I always say
you're married Alexander you're married
a little bit 14 years 14 years 14 yeah
what's what's the secret secret in my
wife you know my advice it's a secret
weapon
[Music]
you know in Keith right now a lot of new
place yeah with good food good cocktails
music and something like that
last few years it's like a boom like
since the Revolution we are in the green
like growing up we're learning the world
all the time and and you're interesting
to speak with the man who are learning
thing and trying to be better that's why
you're interested in cue
[Music]
it's a Peter sonically for any pro from
me bro we're in the heart of the city
right now we're B team right left right
thanks Alan all the island to Hanif
island I mean there's beaches over here
yeah little ones I mean it's not Bali
but it's pretty damn cool for having in
a city Sasha's friend here sim same boat
as you same beautiful hair stylist and
you know just 20 minutes and after work
or before we are surfing at 8 o'clock in
the morning till 10:00 this is my
meditation this is you have to be hot
job job job job I was a member of for
conic team we can came to Kiev with
concerts with some on some TV programs
and I knew at that moment I understood
in that moment that I wanna live in Kiev
and at that moment I was thinking
thinking about parties but you you had a
daughter at the time yeah do you
remember when I say secret in my wife I
had a proposition to be a TV host it
just was a stand-up show I asked my wife
what do you think about it and she said
man you have to go because if you are
not going there all your life you will
be saved and you will be thinking about
that proposition my wife stayed in
Finland ski who is my daughter it was
really hard for for the family a lot of
emotions a lot of job people first money
I went to my own City to them once on
week then once to week once a month when
you're coming in big city you have to
change clothes in mind and when they
came here it was really hard to
understand each other because I changed
but they're still thinking like people
infinite skin small city all the time
your life your family we are going on
theblaze on the plate like on the on the
blade on the blade all the time can cut
your family she didn't understand me and
I didn't understand her and I understood
that that's my daughter she's so cool
ready she looks like me she unbelievable
and that changed me and then I
understood that with a [ __ ] party job
it's only job family is the best thing
what I have
[Music]
here air land and the water
13:14 much woman yeah
Ukrainian surfing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's so so surreal in Ukraine obviously
in a river in the middle October with
these beautiful golden domes in the
distance skyscrapers
wake surfing yeah with my new bro Matt
from California drank
in your brain
almost November
I think I had his thank you
[Music]
bro thank you for that was cool
interesting coming to Ukraine to learn
how to wake wake sir definitely didn't
expect that one like really
who thinks Ukraine and thinks wake
surfing and especially in a city right
what would you say is the difference of
say the the Alexander put on that goes
to the world through these shows and
through your your career and the
Alexander put on behind the scenes you
know all the time I trying to be
Alexander padam sorter or Ukrainians or
for Ukrainian cool guy real guy on TV I
trying to do it it's really hard because
when camera switch on and lighting its
big studio you're trying to be so cool
you know but I'm trying to be real
[Music]
main streets and you on it we can go
just in Hezbollah or the city to see
Ukrainian walls we still care the road
like this and we're in the city
yeah I can go here with my tank we are
going to extreme
[Music]
cereals
Sidious hey there's graffiti everywhere
in the city what is what is that it's
not like gang stuff you know what I mean
what look like there's graffiti haha
it's not the game theorist what is it
kids it's because if I'm in the States
and I see a lot of graffiti in the
neighborhood it's usually it's usually
like a dangerous neighborhood
and note school also I've noticed like
just even where we just went by last
block there's all these art
installations for you to moral morals
yeah very cool oh those newer they've
been around for a while it's it's ten at
this tendance from I think it's just
like two years or three years so that's
Sasha he looks like a nice guy but he
actually hit me
[Applause]
sector Bruce Willis Jason Statham's yeah
yeah I'm a Ukrainian ID by Traverse
license so anybody can come here rent
like a car for a couple hours or
something rent car and take a lesson for
me I need some Sun rules you can drive
and what you can do and when it's wet or
you I hope you can see I had one lesson
before yeah I think I forget that it's
nice knowing you
okay Keith is the city of big
opportunities you can't live here work
here rest here you can feel the freedom
you can find everything
oh yes
that's what she said
oh yeah and I want to I want to hear it
in the evening you know let's go
they say you're breathing hard you've
got yes a workout you want it's right
turn 360 I got it
Sasha got it twice already and it's his
first time today ever nailing the 360
[Music]
understand what what does Mickey what
doesn't mean leave in capital this city
mm I think 10 times bigger than my own
city ten times bigger
should you see can't I just get mad but
yeah okay let's do what we do
yeah see what you're talking about you
killed the wheel Oh
flat tire yeah yeah man is it the
Michael Schumacher uh yeah I can tell
[Music]
you have to to feel it's so you know you
you can you have to find your place
thank you there is a feeling here I feel
it yeah that's why I like it so there's
you know Z layers of city yeah you do it
how long can I stay here I've been here
in Kiev in total about seven months
seven months you are a guy from
California
no thank you because US doesn't have
everything and a lot of people here
think it does and they just dream dream
and us is great for many things but if
you want to get depth in a culture and
in a land the u.s. is not the place the
u.s. is three lifetimes old it's a new
experiment it's beautiful to all the
animals from the zoo in one cage and
they get along for the most part that's
pretty cool here's a tribe this tribe is
together it's 91 something 8% Ukrainians
here it's a very Ukrainian and in that
you feel a certain depth in connect
which I am very attracted to and that's
why I'm choosing to spend this part of
my life and I don't know how long that
lasts
but for now it's very cool and you have
one one more friend it's been awesome
thank you thank you very
[Music]
[Music]